[Music]
oh yeah
the Angela's place is just beyond those
trees no one's gone in or out good thing
we got here in time flew in on a chopper
Bell 412 or the a119 koala it's
classified actually it was the 350 B2
nice but no don't give him the nice hey
there you are and oh my God what is
happening I've got mad and now I'm
getting even okay look sir I know you're
upset but you need to stay calm and
treat this like any other case I mean I
can't believe I'm gonna say this but now
is not the time to go all John Wick
who's that a friend of yours I wish but
he's not a real person he's a movie
assassin that goes nuts when someone
messes with his dog then call me John
Wicks because I'm about to go nuts it's
Wick singular and you already did go
nuts it cost us the trace remember look
I need you to focus the kidnapper texted
his demands how much does the bastard
want for my little doggie that's just it
he doesn't want money he requested all
the files we worked for May 2004. it's a
lead he's got to be connected to one of
those cases somehow interesting you know
what else is interesting grenades just
please stop it I'm gonna take Kevin to
the park where cheddar was kidnapped and
look for Clues I need you to stay here
go through those files and put together
a list of potential suspects can you do
that okay fine
I'll go through the files great
you realize I can't leave until you put
the grenades back right oh but you let
John Wicks have grenades it's Wick
singular
come on oh no
I broke the hotel Key I forgot was in my
wallet for the last five years where's
Rosa we can't wait for her the exam's in
20 minutes it's my fault we're up here
I just won't take the test I'll wait
three years for the next one oh no you
won't
no Jake you are not die Harding off this
room definitely die Harding off this
roof for you and only for you and also
for me because I've always wanted to do
it
[Music]
okay come on get down from there it's
too dangerous it's perfectly safe
seeing hell kiddo what
cars on the window yeah their bars all
the way now
hey
did you take a train trip together
fun
go go go go go
Ray Holt
hello Haynes
thought about you every day I was in
jail just like you said I thought about
pointing a gun at you and pulling the
trigger
kind of like
series back Terry's back we got him nice
work Jefferson
Captain you're doing it
you're emoting
yeah
what happened am I dead you saved my
life
die pigs
[Music]
I'm tired of politics
let's get that punk Bledsoe this is
amazing of course we have no idea where
he is but I love where your head's at he
has no family maybe there was a
girlfriend or someone he worked with at
the coffee shop the coffee shop why
would someone who knows they have 21
million dollars coming take a minimum
wage job because he needed access to
that building because that's where the
money's hidden all right we gotta get
there quick maybe we should take the
chopper
here's that Chopper death blade
Sidewinder it's go time Roger that wet
blanket no from now on call me
velvet Thunder
okay
good morning
hi this is for you thanks quite a big
package you got there oh I apologize for
the double entender I can be such a
Samantha really
you don't seem like a Samantha well I'm
actually a combination of all four
characters five of you count the city of
New York yes
another Sex in the City guilty as
charged my favorite season has to be the
third one everything was going right for
Carrie her face was on every bus her
column was the Talk of the Town and she
met everyone's favorite Furniture maker
Aiden Shawn
sure she melted down when he tried to
introduce her to his parents and she
flipped out when she bumped into the big
getting out of that cab with Natasha and
he had married who can blame her they
barely knew each other the best episode
that year was episode 6 entitled are we
slides you know the one Carrie was all
in her head because she and Aiden
weren't having sex meanwhile across town
Charlotte couldn't stop having sex and
Samantha was just being Samantha the
season finale that year was entitled
cock-a-doodle-doo cock-a-doodle-doo
Roger that
whoops I hate
Carrie should have ended up with Mikhail
Baryshnikov what he's
are you insane
[Music]
got the file preparing for extraction
no screaming Peralta
[Music]
did you ask me they never should have
made the movie Abu Dhabi Abu don't
bother
wow I'm gonna use that please do have a
nice day
well wait hold
on for the ninth floor
all right let me see that envelope oh um
actually I can't show you that because
it's okay
I asked him to come down and mail that
I just need to put my return address on
it and
there you go thanks I know just where to
put that oh
there's Samantha again
[Music]
[Applause]
we did it
what I'm only human you can't always
expect me to be the coolest guy ever
coolest guy ever try telling that to
Alan Greenspan nice burn Bob
okay according to the tracker bodies had
a warehouse on 11th Street ESU is on
site waiting for our go great time to
gear up it's not the best case ever
without some toys oh yeah toys for boys
I don't know if I like that adult toys
still sounds wrong male toys you know
what let's just not call them toys
that's my fault I started it you got it
we'll just call them plate things we
will not let's do this
sniper binoculars here Charles tell me
how far away I am too close to measure
they really work
it's everything
just make too much stuff yeah
and it's too heavy to carry all the way
back
Terry
so you're a cop
I hate cops they gave me this nice
finally a good bad guy this dude gets it
now I'm gonna kill you okay he took a
little too far maybe scale it back skosh
okay start loading out I just have one
piece of business to take care of you
know killing a man is not as easy as it
sounds
I've killed 10 men and that's such a
nice round number when you agree I mean
imagine I've killed 11 people it just
sounds so
cumbersome
get the kayak all the buckets boil you
did it and you completely botched the
catchphrase I'm pretty sure it was right
no but you did great